hey guys today i'm going to explain the
full back story of obara shirakumo and
shota izawa who attended ua together way
back in the day
and dreamt of one day forming a hero
team everything in this video is canon
and comes directly from the spin-off
manga
of which i've done a few videos on
recently so do be sure to check out
those ones after this one
and at the very end i'll explain where
shirakumo is in the current series
although i'll give a big spoiler warning
so no need to worry about that
but without further ado let's get into
it and don't forget to sub
around 15 years before the current
series izawa and shirakuma were both
students in class 2a
and part of a friendship group with
present mike now this storyline in
vigilantes began
with aizawa standing in the rain on his
way to school contemplating whether or
not he should save this abandoned cat
ultimately he decided to leave it there
because he wasn't prepared
for the responsibility of raising it but
he did give up his umbrella so at least
the cat wouldn't get drenched in the
rain which is
you know a pretty nice thing to do
during this period of his life isabel
suffered from
significant self-esteem issues and so
when he made the sensible decision not
to take the cat
in his mind he felt like a failure
because he was unable to truly save it
due to the nature of his quirk he
believed himself to be completely
powerless
and just really an ordinary person who
could never live up to heroes like all
might
that's why when he made it to school
that day he declared that he had a hard
time picturing himself ever becoming a
hero
now naturally president mike took this
statement as an opportunity to joke
around
because nearly everyone except izawa
realizes that his erasure quirk is truly
one of the best around
and this scene is where shirokuma makes
his first ever appearance in the series
as he uses his cloud quirk to fly up to
the third floor of ua and then just let
himself in through the window
for those of you that haven't seen my
video ranking the best quirks in
vigilantes
shurikumo can create these dense clouds
which are capable of uh
carrying heavy objects and he can also
manipulate their size and their movement
with telekinesis
on his arrival shirakuma handed izawa
back the umbrella that he had left in
the rain earlier
and proceeds to strip naked in front of
the entire class
and i'll explain why he stripped naked
in a second but i think now is a good
time to tell you that
it was horikoshi who designed shirokumo
in order to give izawa a
myrio type character in his past many of
you know this already but harukoshi does
not write vigilantes but he did work
together with the writer of vigilantes
to actually flesh out this backstory
that i'm telling you and the reason he
did this is because it directly ties
into the mighty academia manga
later down the road anyway the reason
shirakuma was getting naked in front of
everyone
was to get rid of these wet clothes as
despite having izawa's umbrella right
there
he just didn't use it for some reason i
can't really explain it either but yeah
i mean he gets naked in front of
everyone
and reaches into his crotch area and
pulls out an absolute
beast which on this occasion happens to
be this cat which chota had left behind
unlike izawa's more rational approach
shirokumo came across this cat and
couldn't just leave it there
i mean that pretty much exemplifies him
as a character like he's someone who's
able to make short-term judgments
without hesitation
but like i said he doesn't really
consider the long-term implications of
that
uh like izawa does moving on as is
expected from second years at ua
everyone had secured a work study with
pro heroes with the exception of these
guys which is probably why
president mike said they were referred
to as the three dumigos of class a
their teacher noted that shirokuma was
likely to get a work study
because even though his grades were
average he has a super positive attitude
and similarly for president mike whilst
he was easily distracted
his quirk had a lot of different
potential applications on the other hand
their teacher believed that aizawa would
have a hard time getting any agency to
accept him
as despite his good grades he had no
clear vision
of what kind of hero he was trying to be
and as we know that's because he
couldn't really picture himself as a
hero
this was partly demonstrated during a
joint training exercise with class b
where shota was beaten by sensoji and
this guy is literally just fake back ago
at this stage shoto wasn't really much
of a fighter and
fake bakugou mocked him for the fact
that shota had nothing
but boring tricks to offer if you have
the time i would really encourage
reading the vigilantes manga
and all of sensoji's dialogue just read
it in bakugo's voice i'm telling you
it will change your life also as a side
note shirakuma kept bringing this cat
into school each day
and izaba basically began raising it
like his own son but only during lunch
time
on one occasion these guys were just
chilling on the roof of ua and midnight
was on her way back from a work study
and happened to bump into them
she was already a year ahead of them at
this point so not too far away from
being a pro hero
and her hero costume at this time was
very interesting
because this cat was super cute midnight
wanted to take it off their hands and
raise it herself
at least for the time being and the
dummy goes of ua were more than happy to
let that happen
as they weren't really in a position to
take care of it much longer themselves
although as shirakuma says i mean when
you examine the situation
they did just give the cat away to the
first random girl who walked by
the following day president mike secured
a work study at a battle-focused hero
agency
and he was joined by fake bakugou
meanwhile these two still had no offers
on the table
but luckily midnight appeared out of
nowhere again to show them this video of
the cat pooping
and whilst that was a lovely gesture she
also brought the additional news
that the purple revolution hero agency
was accepting literally anyone for a
work study
this agency was run by his purple
highness who was a flamboyant hero and
also the artist formerly known as prince
his philosophy is quite similar to all
might in that he believes the hero's job
is to smile and give hope to those who
are in trouble
which is why he absolutely destroys
izawa during his first day of the work
study
due to his trademark gloomy expression
on this occasion a villain possessed a
mutation quirk
that allowed him to emit smoke out of
the ding dong on his head as a result
izawa couldn't erase his quirk because
if he got too close then the smoke would
irritate his eyes and if he was too far
away it wouldn't work because of all the
smoke in the way
after the villain made his escape prince
encouraged izawa to trust in his own
power
and shirakumo gave his friend the pair
of goggles that he would typically wear
on his head
and directly because of this help when
they encountered the villain a few days
later
azawa confidently stood in his direct
path and erased his quirk and then
invaded subsequent attacks
shurikuma then swoops in using his cloud
as a trampoline and just knocked the guy
straight out as his purple highness says
together they were almost equivalent to
one single superhero and
if you look here izawa was almost able
to crack a smile
once the new semester began these two
had a pair of goggles each and
according to shirakuma at least they
were marketing themselves as a hero team
as a result they were paired together in
a practical assessment and would face
off against president mike and fake
bakago
i should probably mention that fake
bakugou has a quirk called blast
and it lets him shoot these explosions
directly out of his hands they both have
flashy quirks with tons of power
where as shurikumu and izawa they more
rely on technique
and if you notice here fake bakugou
wears sunglasses as a support item
otherwise his blast would apparently
blind him during battle and thus reduce
his accuracy
because of this he was annoyed with
izawa and shirokumo
for supposedly copying him despite the
fact that he got the idea from president
mike
he then challenges shivakumo and izawa
to a bet that whoever loses this team
battle won't be allowed to wear any
goggles in the future but then for some
reason he proceeds to try and take them
both on
single-handedly like he tells president
mike to stay back remember that at the
beginning of the story
azawa was defeated by sensoji but when
working together with shirakumo
they easily combined to take him out and
knock those glasses right off his face
as we can see in this panel izawa's body
language has improved dramatically
since the beginning of this arc when
working alongside shirakumo he appears
more confident and almost intimidating
but this was not the end of his
development my friends
as the three amigos hatch a plan to
start their own hero agency in the
future
the plan was that shota would nullify
the villains and then present mike and
shirokumo
would swoop in and finish off the job
although as we see in this panel
shota initially interpreted this as them
saying that he couldn't actually do
anything on his own and when we look at
the type of hero that he became
it's clear that he worked super hard to
overcome this insecurity
as we've seen time and time again that
he's able to defeat you know
powerful villains just one versus one by
himself now just one week after this
conversation
an event would happen that would
drastically change the course of their
entire lives
in this situation a villain attack was
underway in a place called tasumiya
and i hope i said that right and the
hero team known as buster union was sent
to take care of it this is meant to be
the hardest hitting hero team around
and they also had two interns who were
fake back ago
and present mike the criminal in
question was this giant creature known
as garvey
who had already been convicted of
several offenses including murder his
quirk allows him to absorb the physical
attacks of anyone
and then store it in his back and then
he can release them at any point you
know
whenever he feels like it he can shoot
it right back at the heroes and as we
see he was on a complete rampage
but once boston union showed up they
only made the situation worse
as they used their combined firepower to
attack him which then only gave him more
ammo to use for his destruction
garvey used some of his quirks to defeat
them all in an instant
and whilst all this was going on izal
and shirakuma were in the neighborhood
helping out with a group of kids his
purple highness and midnight
were a bit closer to the destruction and
they let shirokuma and izama know what
was happening
so that they could begin evacuation but
before they could even
do that garvey appeared apparently he
was actually pretty fast for a guy of
his size
and his purple highness intervened to
take him down but just like the other
heroes he was easily blown away
and then he suffered a follow-up blast
which was pretty brutal
as a consequence the building began to
crash down with the debris heading
straight towards these children here
we've already established that shirokumo
is a decisive thinker like he can think
quickly right
and he instinctively creates a cloud
which is dense enough
to protect everyone from the falling
concrete however in the process of doing
that
he was unable to protect himself and was
sadly hit in the head by a big slab
which is not something that most people
come back from
what that meant is that at this moment
aizawa is now the only one who's able to
take on garvey
but could you imagine how scary it would
be to you know your friend has just been
mortally wounded and an entire hero team
has been blown away
and you're the only one who can you know
take him on one versus one despite that
the formerly timid and unconfident isawa
goes into full-blown hero mode and takes
on this beast of a man
all by himself using his crazy
intelligence his initial strategy was to
go above garvey's head
so that any attacks he made would be
directed to the sky his second plan was
to stare at these quirk balls
and then kind of stop them from
detonating and then kick them into the
sky as high as possible
then enabling them to release at a safe
distance and this was all well and good
but garvey was able to land a hit
on shota which left him wondering how he
could actually win the fight
rather than just stalling he then hears
shirakuma's voice telling him to get up
and motivating him
to carry on the voice came from the
speaker that shirakuma usually carried
around with him
and he usually carried this around as a
support item to deceive enemies as to
his location
and this pep talk from shirakumo gives
isa with the adrenaline boost that he
needs to begin whooping garvey
i'm talking punches to the eye and then
the finishing move which was gathering
all these stocked quirks and then
releasing them
inside of garvey's mouth not bad for a
second-year student not bad at all
with the battle seemingly over garvey is
apprehended by the police and the
wounded heroes
are taken to be patched up however there
is one person who didn't make it
and that my friends as you would expect
was shirakumo
according to sensoji the speaker was
broken the entire
time meaning that the words of
encouragement that aizawa was hearing
they just came from his brain like he
was just imagining it because it was a
life or death situation
so even though he single-handedly
defeated a villain that a top-rated hero
team couldn't beat altogether
he had lost his best friend and teammate
in the process
the potential future that they dreamt of
together it died in that moment and
resulted in a big change
for this character over the course of
the next year shota performed
intense solo training to become a true
fighter and according to president mike
this is what caused him to become the
sleepy guy that we know today
as he always needed to rest and recover
we see a few class a students talking
about you know teaming up for the sports
festival
but shota as you can see in this panel
he literally could not care less
this is because he has zero interest in
impressing the hero agencies or the
heroes you might be watching
and instead he controversially set his
sights on becoming an underground hero
who specializes
in anti-villain combat this is quite
unusual for ua graduates
as they normally always work at a hero
agency before going independent
additionally he stopped caring about his
academics like he used to
and he would stop trying once he
achieved a passing grade according to
his teacher
the only thing he had passion for
anymore was the battle exercises
the last fight that we see young izawa
have at ua was a one-on-one clash with
fake bakugou
and this time he absolutely floors him
with an elbow to the chest
when you compare that to the beginning
of the story it's unreal how much he's
grown in not too long of a period of
time
and it makes you think like how much can
the current class 1a how much can they
grow in the present day given that they
have over two years before they graduate
on the day of isabel's graduation
everyone's getting ready to take class
photos but
as president mike goes to call him shota
erases his quirk and then gives him a
cheeky smile
before immediately jumping off and
beginning his epic hero career
for those of you who don't want to know
major spoilers surrounding shirakumo and
his death and everything
then please sub to the channel and pause
the video at this moment to avoid
spoilers
for the rest of you let's get into the
insane truth about this character
as it turns out after shirokumo died all
for one swapped out his body before it
was cremated
and with the help of dr ujiko his corpse
was turned into a nomu
all for one said in the manga that they
did this because at uwa
that is where the best quirks are all
you know put together
so he said that if you could take a ua
student's quirk that would be
i think he compared it to like drinking
fine wine multiple quirk factors were
fused into shirakuma's original body
until he became the creature known as
kurigiri now this was a crazy plot twist
in the manga because
we've known kirigiri since season one
and but we had no idea that you know he
used to be
was old best friend and if you look at
the intro for season one
i mean kirigiri's eyes flash and then
isabel's flash immediately after like
it's almost like he was foreshadowing
this
and it's so funny because in much the
same way that shirokumo
you know he cared for izawa and you know
developed his confidence in the same way
he helped izawa
now he's helping shigeraki to grow and
develop him into the next successor to
all for one but anyway thanks for
watching i really appreciate it
i also really appreciate the fact that
we hit 70 000 subscribers
that's pretty insane thanks for watching
and peace out